Speaker 1: This is a crazy story. I
thought this was fake when I first
heard about it. Lauren Boebert
is about to be a grandmother.
Now. I know. I know you're saying. Wait, Lauren
Boebert. How old is she? Lauren Boebert is 36
years old, and she is about to be a grandmother
because her teenage son is going to be having a
baby next month. And listen, there are a lot of
cultural differences between different parts of
the country. There's no doubt about that. And
it is much less common in parts of the country,
more liberal parts of the country to see something
like this celebrated. And I'll tell you why in a
moment with some statistics. But Lauren Boebert
is celebrating it. Lauren Boebert is acting like
it's a good thing that she, as a former teen
mom, is now going to be a grandmother thanks to
her son becoming a teen dad. Let's take a look
at this big announcement from Lauren Boebert.
This is there's a lot here. Okay.
Speaker 3: I'm a mom of four boys.
And I've said many times, Jason and I, we are
raising our four boys to be men. Okay. Before
liberals teach them to be women.
Speaker 1:
Okay.
Speaker 3: But I leaned over and I
asked my husband if it was appropriate to announce
this here today. So I'm going to tell you all for
the first time in a public setting that not only
am I a mom of four boys. But come April. I will
vague to a grand a brand new grandson. Wow.
Speaker 1: Even this crowd is sort of like,
okay, yeah, kind of like a
muted reaction, I have to say.
Speaker 3: And Jason and I are so excited
to welcome this new life into our family.
Now, any of you who have young children. Who are
giving life. There are some questions that pop up.
Speaker 1: There's there are a hell
of a lot of questions popping up based
on what she's saying. That's for.
Speaker 3: Sure. Fear that arises.
Now, my son, when I approached him and told him,
Tyler, I'm going to be a 36 year old grandmother.
He said, Well, didn't you make Granny
a 36 year old granny? Said, Yes, I did.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: He said, Well, then it's hereditary.
Speaker 1: Now, that's pretty interesting,
actually. There's actually a lot there.
And here's an additional clip again,
where Lauren Boebert, she talks about.
She she talks about this like it's a good thing
and she wants to make it a cultural thing. She
wants out. How great is it that the culture of
life in red states leads to a high teen birthrate?
Speaker 3: And, you know, there's something
special about rural conservative communities.
Speaker 1: Yes, there is.
Speaker 3:
They value life. If you look at teen
pregnancy rates throughout the nation,
well, they're the same in rural and urban areas.
However, abortion rates are higher in urban
areas and teen mom rates are higher in rural
conservative areas because we understand the
preciousness of the life that is about to be born.
Speaker 1: And wow. So a few different things.
Now, I don't want to make this into a cultural
critique. There is a cultural critique here to
be made without a doubt. Okay? But by their own
claims, by their own claims, it's not really
clear to me that these really are the pro-life
values as exhibited by teens who get pregnant
in red states not seeking abortions. I don't
think that that's the great thing to celebrate
that Lauren Boebert is making it out to be,
because the most important thing to look at here
is how do the kids of teen parents do in life and
the children of young mothers do notably less well
in life? This is not about saying Lauren Boebert
grandkid deserves to do poorly. The grandkid I
would consider a victim in this situation. It's
that the kid is not being well set up to succeed.
When you look at outcomes of all sorts and types
poverty, how likely to graduate high school,
all of these different things. You see the ideal
outcomes when the parents or usually what they're
looking at is the mother is at least 25 years
old, and then from 20 to 25 year old moms,
you see less good outcomes. And then when the mom
is under 20, you see absolutely the worst outcomes
and the difference is significant. Now, this isn't
about saying a 19 year old can't be a good mom.
Of course that's not the case. This isn't about
saying if you're 18 and you have a kid you love
the kid any less, or it is not about that. But
the younger the mother is, the higher the rate of
poverty, the less likely the child is to graduate
high school. You get the picture. But then we get
not only to the weirdness of celebrating this,
when we know that statistically it's actually
not a good thing. The hypocrisy here is that the
way to prevent this, if you think it's not a good
thing now, Lauren Boebert seems to be celebrating
it. Okay. There is a cultural aspect to this. If
you think this isn't a good thing, the way to
prevent it is, of course, safe legal access to
abortion. We know that. But teaching comprehensive
sex education that reduces teen pregnancy, it's
been studied widely. Comprehensive sex ed reduces
teen pregnancy. Lauren Boebert is against that.
Lauren Boebert recently voted against funding
that. And so there is that aspect to it as well,
which is she is partially to blame. Certainly
her movement is to blame for the creation of
the circumstances that got us here in the first
place. And by the way, Lauren Boebert also says
that children should be forced to wait until their
age 21 to make decisions about just even what
their gender expression is going to be. But having
a baby at 17 is a great thing and is fine. That's
also another one of these stunning hypocrisy.
So listen there. When we talk about different,
different American cultures, this is one
aspect that is very, very different. And
to what degree some of what she's doing is
a rationalization because the cake is baked,
for lack of a better term. I don't know. But
it is really, really wacky stuff. If you want
to see Lauren Boebert deliver this news to this
titillated crowd. All of these clips that I played
will be on our Instagram, which you can find
by searching Instagram for David Pakman show.